really liking what you do whatever area
that you get into given that you know
even if you if you're the best the best
there's always a chance of failure so I
think it's important that you really
like whatever you're doing if you don't
like it life is too short if you like
what you're doing you think about it
even when you're not working I mean
it'll just it's it's something that your
mind is drawn to and and if you don't
like it you just really can't make it
work and now is the time to take risk
you don't have kids as you get older
your obligations increase so your and
once you have a family you start taking
risk not just for yourself but for your
family as well it gets much harder to do
things that might not work out so now is
the time to do that before you before
you have those obligations so I would
encourage you to take risks now do
something bold you want to regret it
you just watch two amazing clip some
Elon Musk take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how to apply
them to your business and your life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]